[Music]
welcome to this Sky News special program
live from Manchester Crown Court on the
murder of Olivia Pratt Corbell today a
guilty verdict and some justice for her
family
it's been more than seven months since
Olivia was shot dead in her home in
Liverpool at the age of just nine years
old her death sent shockwaves through
the local community and across the
country
Olivia's mother after hearing the
verdict left caught clutching her
daughter's teddy bear
The Man convicted of Olivia's murder a
drug dealer Thomas Cashman is due to be
sentenced on Monday
well there were gasps and tears from
Olivia's family as Thomas Cashman was
found guilty of murder attempted murder
wounding with intent to Grievous bodily
harm and two charges of possession of
firearms throughout the trial which
lasted more than three weeks he had
consistently denied being the gunman in
the attack the senior investigating
officer described the situation as
something unlike anything he'd
encountered in his nearly 30 years of
policing this is my report on the murder
that shot the nation
in the dark on a Liverpool Street these
were the moments that were to lead to
tragedy Thomas Cashman marked by police
with a blue dot pursuing his intended
victim a man called Joseph knee marked
here in red
[Music]
the gunfire recorded on a security
camera and shown to the jury it was the
next shot that was to prove fatal to a
young girl
Olivia Pratt Corbell was just nine years
old a unique chatty nosy little girl her
family said Who Loved life and all it
had to offer it was a life cut short by
a gunman who'd gone out to kill
a jury deciding that that gunman was
Cashman whose ruthless Pursuit took the
shooting inside Olivia's home
what Olivia's mother Cheryl made of the
verdict was clear to see as she left
court she and her family sat through the
trial for them and for police a moment
of relief
the circumstances around it were just
abundance and she was cowering behind
them all because she was scared in her
own home
he always feel as though you're safe in
your own house
I think as an investigation team we
could not believe
that the government would continue to
shoot into the house
I don't think we've ever seen anything
like that before
Community have been discoursed
by his actions
they've been in fear of him for a long
long time
he will know himself
and have to carry that responsibility
Olivia's mum Cheryl was injured by the
bullet that killed her daughter the jury
heard her description of that night the
moment she knew Olivia in her words was
gone
this was that intended target that night
convicted burglar knee police say it was
a petty dispute
on suspicious
Cashman had denied being the gunman he
said he was going about his business as
a high-level cannabis dealer that night
but the trial heard from a witness who
said he'd gone to her home after the
shooting looking for a change of clothes
and admitting having done Joey knee
police have commended her bravery in
coming forward at no time police say as
Cashman shown any remorse is a coward
he's despicable
he made great play in the in the trial
that he is a dad
and yet he's put Olivia's family through
this trial I hope he reflects every
morning when he wakes up behind bars and
every night when he goes to sleep
about what he's put Olivia's family
through
the guns used that night have still not
been recovered police say this
investigation continues even after a
lengthy and complex prosecution we're
only a small wheel in the Cog here of
you know nothing will bring Olivia back
this is just for the family some sense
of justice the person who ruined their
lives is nicely
you know we've not got Justice for them
Cashman was driven away from court but
will be back there on Monday to be
sentenced police say Olivia's death
should not be in vain a girl of wit and
kindness her family said whose life was
short but whose personality certainly
wasn't
well the merseyside police and crime
commissioner Emily Sparrow joins me now
from Liverpool good evening to you and
thanks very much for joining us I
remember talking to you in the aftermath
of the shooting on on Kings Heath Avenue
when you think back to that day and you
think back to think of today and where
we are what do you think this moment
means
primarily for Liverpool
firstly I just want to offer you know my
heart my heart out goes out to uh Cheryl
and all of Olivia's family and loved
ones I can't imagine what they will have
been through over the last few weeks
obviously nothing is going to bring back
their beautiful chatty little girl
um but I do hope this does offer some
comfort to them that Cashman is now
going to be facing a life sentence and
will be off the streets of merseyside
and for the city obviously people there
have been following this trial what do
you think this this means to to the to
the community and the and the wider city
as well
absolutely
guns in our city and we heard that
message very loud and clear last summer
after the awful incident I'm incredibly
grateful to the community those who
particularly came forward who supported
the family but who shared information
who contacted the police who went
through Crime Stoppers I think it's
Testament to them and their hard work
and their bravery that we've been able
to get the right verdict here at court
today and I think everybody across
Liverpool and the whole of merseyside is
pleased that we've got the the result
today
I was going to ask you that it was clear
looking at the the senior members of the
investigating team this week the the
strain of of what they've had to do over
the last uh seven months and a a complex
a big investigation in the in the public
eye as well how do you think they'll be
feeling about the the job they have done
in in persuading the jury in putting
that case to the jury that was that
proved successful in the in securing
this conviction
I'm incredibly grateful to the work of
our police officers and staff as well as
the CPS they have worked tirelessly to
get this result today but they
absolutely couldn't have done it without
that support from the community those
people who have come forward and given
that information and I want to reassure
the public that the police will act on
this information whenever something like
this happens they take this seriously
they want to get the right outcome and
ultimately today they've been able to
secure that justice so I'm very proud
and very grateful for the whole work
they've done to get Justice for Olivia's
family today
the police have said the senior
investigating officer has said that of
clearly the guns that were used on that
night are still out there they've
appealed to whoever is holding those
guns or knows where they are to come
forward
um that shows I guess that there is
still a lot of work to be done what's
your message to to the to the people of
Liverpool on on that front of what still
needs to be done
merseyside police is Relentless in its
pursuit of tackling serious and
organized crime we have seen the lowest
Firearms discharges in recent years but
clearly as you say there is still more
work to be done most side police are
regularly regarded as one of the best
for tackling this issue particularly
around Firearms they want to understand
where those guns are being held they
want to know what types of weapons are
out there and again it comes back to
that brilliant support that we get from
the community they absolutely can't do
this without that support they will
continue that work and we will invest in
our communities but we need everybody to
come forward and share any information
either anonymously through Crime
Stoppers or direct to the police and the
police will act on it
there was a lot of talk at the time
wasn't there about this this wall of
Silence whether it existed or not and
the police have said that it didn't it
didn't exist it it wasn't a factor in
this case that people were coming up to
police cordons and giving information
that they were were handing over CCTV
much of which we saw during the course
of this of this trial the communities
part in this investigation and this
conviction is is pretty clear isn't it
it absolutely is and I think we saw in
the outcry that we saw last summer how
much the whole Community across
Liverpool across merseyside was was
shocked by this people wanted to get
Justice for Olivia and for her family
and I think that just shows in terms of
the quality the numbers of people who
came forward those individuals who
bravely uh you know gave evidence
throughout the court trial absolutely we
could not have secured this bird today
without them and I'm incredibly grateful
for all the support they've offered
the police talked about the need to get
guns off the streets clearly Cashman
himself said he was a high level
cannabis dealer that the police said
that people had lived in fear of him for
some time those issues of dealing with
with drugs and guns how do you reassure
the public that they are being dealt
with that the police are able to solve
those problems because of course we
still see guns being used on the streets
not just in Liverpool of course how do
you persuade people that that
things will improve
well as I say Mercer police is regarded
as one of the best in the country for
tackling serious and organized crime
particularly that focus on Firearms
we've seen the lowest numbers um in
almost 20 years so I think we are seeing
progress being made one of the
initiatives that we managed to develop
after the incident last summer we
secured additional funding was to
further all out our clear hold build
program this is very much going in and
clearing out those individuals who would
seek to cause that harm and misery
within our communities get rid of them
but then importantly we go back into
those communities and we work together
with them with our partners and we
support them to build that resilience so
actually those individuals that we've
cleared out they can't come back in they
can't take hold we support our young
people to go on a better path and it's
all about how we can create that
long-lasting change so these gangs
cannot take hold of communities again
Emily sporel the police and crime
commissioner for merseyside thanks very
much for joining us uh there from
Liverpool this evening well Sky News has
been analyzing the known movements of
Thomas Cashman as set out in court by
the prosecution on the day that Olivia
died
making multiple Journeys throughout the
day Thomas Cashman returned to his house
for eight minutes before leaving again
at 8 30 p.m he drove around the local
area before parking his car and walking
to Finch Lane where he waited for more
than 30 minutes for Joseph knee
Joseph knee was at an address on Finch
Lane watching a football match with a
friend which finished at 9 52 shortly
afterwards knee left the house with his
friend and turned on to Kings Heath
Avenue
CCTV footage captured Joseph knee being
pursued by Thomas Cashman at 9 59 shots
were fired
Joseph knee then ran into the driveway
of the Corbell house Thomas Cashman
fired into the house this was the moment
Olivia Pratt Corbell was shot Thomas
Cashman fled the scene running through
back Gardens Joseph knee was picked up
by a car
without the story of that day in August
well Ian Byrne is the MP for West Derby
where Olivia lived he sold Sky News that
more funding does need to be dedicated
to stopping young people from entering a
life of crime
single pathology's Legacy hopefully be
you know changing
how we ensure that the youth have got an
opportunity to use funding you know how
Olivier
what happened isn't in vain you know
that we look at the societal issues
which have led
to the tragic death of Olivia you know
how she was taken away from her family
how she was put in these other
circumstances arose in which she lost
her life you know to so many so many
questions uh that we need answers to
both within our own communities but also
from a national point of view as well so
you know for me hopefully I'll be I'll
be raising them questions I'll be
looking for answers and it's about
rebuilding
the community most importantly Olivia
the mom Olivia's family how they come
together you know hopefully this is a
the first part of you know you know of
that process
well Ian Byrne MP there well the acting
Bishop of Liverpool Beverly Mason uh
joins us now live from from Liverpool
and good evening to you and thank you
very much for taking time to talk to us
this evening I wonder what you make of
the reaction in the city uh to to what's
happened here in Manchester today and
and what's been the end of a a very long
process for the people of the city and
of course the for Olivia's family
it's felt like a very long process
hasn't it and in real terms it hasn't
been that long uh the police
um have done an extraordinary job people
in the community have done an
extraordinary extraordinary job there's
people who have stepped up and stepped
out spoken up spoken out and some at
enormous costs to themselves so I think
the city has a profound sense of
gratitude to to all of those people who
have brought Thomas Cashman to um to
Justice
there was a lot of talk in in August
about the the needs of the community and
how it was being blighted by these
issues of gang violence and increasingly
gun violence and drugs as well what do
you sense that the mood is now are
people seeing change do they feel that
that Watershed that was talked about so
much
um has has arrived that things are
changing
there was a horrible Spate of gun crime
wasn't there one after the other and and
it left us reeling
um and uh and there was an outcry you
know people were saying this is not our
city Liverpool is a fantastic City it's
vibrant it's colorful it's welcoming
it's full of hospitality and um it's not
our city you know we don't we don't want
it we have no truck with this kind of um
this kind of uh violence and behaviors
is shocking and so I I think we stand
with one voice behind
um Cheryl and the family
um and saying you know that this just is
not acceptable this is not our city
what are your thoughts about someone
like Cashman on a night like tonight uh
he faces of course a life sentence uh in
prison what do you feel about about him
tonight
I feel like justice justice justice has
happened you know there's there's a
verdict
um the verdict is sound it was unanimous
and um and it seems right and proper and
I I think um that without Justice there
can never truly be peace I wonder I
don't believe there can be be peace
without Justice and so my hope and
prayer now is for for Cheryl and the
family
um that they will they will start
piecing together the shards of their
broken hearts and and start to live all
of this has been hanging over them for
what must have felt like an eternity and
um you know there must be so many
questions uh and and they've had to
forensically relive everything and so I
hope that this will give them the
verdict will give them some sense of of
closure at least on on this uh this this
horrible episode in their life and
enable them to start living their lives
in the light and blessing and joy of of
all that Olivia has brought to them
I'm sure the whole country would agree
with you we just heard a little while
ago from Ian Byrne the MP for West Derby
uh talking about the need to try to turn
young people away from from that gang
culture that we've heard a lot about in
the trial and the life that Cashman uh
LED what do you think the answer is to
that how how do you turn away young
people who who might see that as a a
glamorous exciting way of life or
certainly numbers seem to be attracted
to that way of life what's the answer to
that question
we have to tell a different story and we
have to invest in our young people if we
don't others will uh that that's the
bottom line isn't it and so we need to
to look at how we are investing
investing in our young people
um the clear hold bold project and work
that's been done around that is
absolutely crucial I'm very proud of the
work done by our churches and being done
by our churches and connecting with
schools counselors
um and and and and
people involved in the community to tell
that different story and evolved in
regenerating effectively this is crucial
work there needs to be more investment
in this type of work
people talk a lot about Rhys Jones and
the fact that Olivia died 15 years to
the day after Rhys Jones died as a
result of of gun violence that was said
to be a watershed just finally do you
hope this is a a watershed for for
Liverpool and these these issues that um
have Arisen in in quite a short space of
time
we never forget Olivia I pray that the
city never regret never never forgets
Olivia just as it hasn't forgotten
um forgotten all these people these
young people whose lives have been
snuffled up from them and snuffled up
from the world it's it's an outrage it's
a blot Against Humanity we cannot forget
but in the remembering we need to
um I believe just hold the light and we
can live a better life we can create a
better world but it requires our
commitment so my hope and prayer for
this city as it is for for this nation
is that um rather than being formed by
and having fear instilled in Us by the
terrible things that happen actually
they become immense motivators to work
for a bigger better brighter world
Beverly Mason the acting Bishop of
Liverpool thank you very much for your
time uh with us this evening live there
in uh in Liverpool as the city reflects
on this uh verdict uh here at Manchester
Crown Court uh today well the chair of
merseyside's police and crime panel
Barbara Murray says the community was
extremely Cooperative with the police in
carrying out this investigation
I'm really proud of this community there
was nothing like a wall of Silence
um I personally heard Batman within 48
hours from several different sources
um our people oh
or people who live here wanted Justice
and they came forward and they spoke to
the police and the police are quite
right to give them uh recognition for
what they did because they were very
brain we're talking about people who are
not
um
not like us if you like the violent they
use guns and so despite the fear people
might have had they did give back
intelligence to the police and I'm very
proud of them
Barbara Murray there from the other
merseyside police and crime panel while
our crime correspondent Martin brand
joins me now live now from uh Liverpool
and Martin we saw the relief for the
family we saw the relief for the police
but for the city as well uh this is a
significant moment
yes indeed I think we saw the relief on
the face of um Cheryl Olivia's mother as
she left court
um you know almost triumphant
um but set against of course the awful
tragedy of her daughter's death
um
and I'm sure that's widely reflected in
in the city tonight because of course
you know there is relief because this
wasn't the strongest prosecution case uh
the prosecution didn't suggest a firm
motive they didn't get any forensic
evidence they didn't find the weapons
um but what they did do was put together
a compelling case of circumstantial
evidence certainly enough to convince
the jury now a few days ago as we waited
for the jury to deliver its verdict I
went around part of Liverpool the area
where Olivia was murdered with a
reformed gangster and one of the things
we talked about was the conflict that
people face on occasions like this where
outrage and and horror and the need for
justice is always balanced against
loyalty and fear of being called a grass
and informing on the please how do you
wrestle with that issue of giving
information to the police this is the
report I did
we got into firearms and guns at 21.
and then just escalated us from there
zacarius McGrath was a major Liverpool
gangster he once roamed these streets
where guns are used to enforce drug
Empires I was mentioning all share cause
I was mentioned in all situations so I'm
a bit of a hypocrite to stand here now
and say you know they're absolutely to
come which they are but I was one I was
once that same scumbag and you put guns
on the streets by your own admission I
think yeah in massive volumes
when Olivia was shot the community was
in Conflict outrage balanced against
loyalty and fear of being called a grass
probably people are going to be in
locklands and I think depend on who
commits the mayor then if they're
established gang members then people are
going to be more reluctant police
struggle to get the evidence they needed
for Olivia's murder
everyone says there's a Code no question
no no this no doubt if it benefits can
most they will they will grasp each
other up it's what benefits them they're
not just going to do for charity but for
the members of the public who witness a
big crime how difficult is it for them
do you think to give information it's
going to be overwhelming it's going to
be scary and they're not really going to
want to get involved well when it's a
child I think the real big goes out to
win them but they will worry weren't
they about their own safety afterwards
if people find out that's where the
police to go nobody but that's where the
police to to reassure them that they're
gonna protect them and ensure their
safety
police heard from one key witness early
on but got no direct evidence no one who
could identify the gunman no forensics
no weapon a reward of fifty thousand
pounds wasn't doing the trick it was
boosted with another hundred thousand
from an anonymous donor a businessman
from merseyside the charity topped it up
to a record two hundred thousand pounds
when I heard there was a reluctance for
people to come forward and testify
that's what really got my back up I
thought well I'm gonna do something
about this it was an amount that would
make people sit up and take notice the
bottom line is that this was horrific
the murder of a young girl it doesn't
come much worse than that sixteen years
ago a young boy Rhys Jones was shot dead
only a few miles from here I reported on
it sicarius was in prison but we both
heard the loud calls for change
they always say that whenever there's a
young person stabbed or shot
and they say enough is enough and
they're going to take a standbook
communities never do it's just all words
a couple of days or a couple weeks later
they just go back to doing what he was
doing and forget about it it's only the
families that are left suffering last
August Olivia's death was one of three
gun murders in a week
there have been two more in the city
since
Marty brunt Sky News in Liverpool
well I'm joined Now by Mandy Jameson
who's 16 year old son Danny was killed
in Liverpool in 2018 and Mandy thanks
for for talking to us tonight I'm sure
we could all only imagine what you must
feel when you hear stories like this and
I know you've met Cheryl Corbell what
are your feelings tonight for her and
her family
I'm just so glad that she got the
outcome that she wanted
um
I'm glad that it's over for her it's not
going to bring the baby back obviously
um but I'm just glad to tell you but I
mean she should never have been put
through that trial I think it's awful
the victim families have to go through
all this
there's no consideration for how all
this has affected us I'd like to
actually see how he would have acted if
it was one of his children that got made
as you know maybe a different thing and
the carry on office family outside that
could they should be absolute shamed of
themselves how dare they carry on like
that she was a baby she was only nine
years away just like everybody was only
12. this is just appalling they were
planning on off them I'm just glad the
Shadow's got a little bit of peace I
know it's not going to be over and again
she'll wake up tomorrow and Olivia's
still going to be gone but at least
she's got some kind of Justice from this
um it's just so sad as I say people
don't realize it's hard work being a
grievable mother
every day it's exactly the same same
pain
every day you wake up you realize that
your child's no longer here anymore
and people just don't get it you know
and the fact that they put her through
18 days of having to relive that every
single day is strong and I'm just glad I
hope that the judge never lets his man
out and again I think his family needs
to hang their heads and shame and say
the carrying on like that outside of the
course it's awful
really is
yeah I know you've you I know you've
said that it being a grieving mother is
like living a life sentence what what do
you hope the police have said it that
she cannot Olivia cannot have died in
vain what do you think would need to
change to make that come true to really
to make sure that she didn't die in vain
we need to get rid of this grassland
mentality in Liverpool that's absolutely
awful when children are losing their
lives and people don't talk I just think
it's horrendous I mean again I'd like to
see how they would deal with it
themselves if it happened to one of
their children I think that parents need
to start standing up to their children
um you see the kids nowadays seem to be
getting away with so much which is
resulting but again the way Castleman
has carried on because he's got away
with it all his life
um I just don't understand the justice
system sometimes I mean I know the
police wear cards and without the police
we'd have absolute chaos we need to
bring more early interventions I think
into Liverpool where we're showing
people which is what we're trying to do
now is that you know you can't carry on
like this there's a different part for
you to take
um we just don't seem to be getting no
support but those should be honest I
mean I can shout about this all day
but nothing ever changes nothing hasn't
given the four years since Daniel was
taken nothing has changed and like even
with Eva
I mean we're still in the same situation
we are on the kids is going younger and
younger I mean Daniel was 16 Ava was 12.
baby Olivia was only nine what are we
gonna do go lower than that now do you
all want to grow up and stop terrorizing
people
if you can't use your face don't fight
don't be picking up guns or weapons or
anything like that it's just wrong we're
out into you know dealing with the
old-fashioned way instead of picking
weapons up
people don't understand the damage that
it does to us you know honestly they
don't they just think oh yeah just a
kid's being killed did you see the
aftermath of it the ripple effect where
it damages families
it's just hard it really is you know it
is like living a life sentence for us I
know he's gone to jail no but Cheryl has
got to redo this every single day for
the rest of her life because this pain
doesn't go away it stays with you
forever
Mandy Jameson and we appreciate your
thoughts on what's a difficult day I'm
sure for you and clearly for for
Olivia's family as well but thank you
for your uh time with us live from
Liverpool there well it is a story that
has shocked the nation a nine-year-old
girl killed in her own home as she hid
behind uh her mother
for the family some justice today as
Thomas Cashman was found guilty of her
murder he'll be sentenced on Monday